il court pour faire avancer les causes
qui lui tiennent à cœur depuis deux mois
et demi guillah Malfitano avale 43 km
par jour l'équivalent d'un marathon et
en se 66e jour d'aventure cette athlète
unijambiste s'attendait à un effort
solitaire un exploit quotidien dont il a
le secret mais à 5 km de l'arrivée Guy
et frôlé par un camion qui a perdu le
contrôle et finit sa course de l'autre
côté de la chaussée dans sa direction
j'ai entendu un crissement j'ai juste eu
le temps de tourner la tête et j'ai vu
le camion qui zigzaguer et la cabine
elle est arrivée à foncé sur moi j'ai eu
juste le temps j'ai sauté dans le dans
le fossé il m'a fusillé la béquille
droite et puis voilà et puis j'ai un
petit j'ai un petit pet au pouce mais
ouais là j'ai bien cru que c'était ma
dernière
le Gascon décide de repartir au courage
mais sans ces béquilles de course mouler
à son bras son entourage est à peine
étonné d'une telle combativité ça a
toujours été un guerrier mais là je
dirais qu'aujourd'hui avec ce qui vient
de se passer c'est enfin
il montre encore des ressources
incroyables parce que il veut pas lâcher
les prêtres partir donc on est en train
de s'organiser pour essayer de d'assurer
le
les réparations je me suis vraiment
engagé pour pour ça pour soutenir des
associations
là c'est en l'occurrence pour cette
région c'est l'association un bracelet
contre le cancer donc je suis forcément
sensibiliser à ça puisque moi j'ai perdu
ma jambe à l'âge de 17 ans suite à un
cancer donc voilà ça me tient à cœur et
et je vais arriver au bout qui a
Malfitano veut croire que son aventure
n'est pas terminée fauché sur une route
de Côte-d'Or et qu'il pourra la
reprendre dès demain malgré le
contrecoup et les incertitudes sur ses
béquilles à travers son périple qui
accompagne neuf associations en
collectant pour elle des fois